pediram também fazer uma música que tem
no meu disco
na verdade ela é um pouco amor de uma
poesia é eu trouxe ela de corpo que
entre o teste ela né grau já devia ter
decorado é real e pediram pra mim fazer
a eu gostaria de dedicar essa música
para a dona não em mim pelo fato de que
há um sério
sempre que alguém é uma música que fala
de amor mas sempre que alguém me
pergunta se eu vivi isso aqui ou
qualquer coisa do tipo
lá há a meta é a gente batalha todo
disse ali se está acreditando é vencer
onde o mesmo trata acontecendo e é isso
então nem engatamos nos relacionamos e é
isso a vida é essa aí mas hoje eu vi que
quando escreveu esse bagulho aqui muita
gente falou que era o tópico pá e eu vi
que a relação da senhora é essa
essa parada aqui e obrigados e deu vazão
a música existe eu vou ler como se fosse
a poesia até porque ela não tem rima
liberta de e aí tudo bom
eu só queria te dizer que eu acredito
que oferte é a forma que o amor encontra
para mostrar que apesar de ser velho
como a morte permanece novo como uma
criança eterno como tempo encontrar com
que se gosta transforma seu olhar um
pedaço de céu de ano novo e seu coração
em pista de dança
nossos beijos fazer com que amor de
cinema sejam superficiais demais pra
compreender a profundidade que a gente
se conhece
pintamos o céu nas cores de uma nebulosa
fazemos a lua sente inveja de não ter
alguém ea vizinha de seu apartamento
saber nacional
somos a chance pro no dia 2
você não deve ser de atenção com cheiro
de morango e champanhe cada fim do dia
é como se o mundo acabasse pra começar
de novo
assistimos o fim do mundo toda a noite
de camarote com os pés na janela e as
pernas entrelaçadas vendo estrelas
cochichando todos os segredos do mundo
entre elas com o tempo eu entendi que
você é tudo aquilo que eu não sei
explicar
nós somos um casal de metrô não temos
medo nem vergonha
temos desejo já percebeu que deseja cega
e eu sou cego de paixão por você defina
quanto pesa um suspiro que eu defino do
que é feita essa paixão suas palavras
meu silêncio tem um caso de amor cada
vez que ficam juntos trânsito no som de
diálogo e os filhos desta relação nasce
nas noites em claro em que passamos o
telefone
nós somos o são de beijo na chuva eu
sinto que cada verso que eu faço é como
se ele devesse um imposto aos seus lados
quando a gente discute sua voz soul a
cunhas numa lusa
você ao som de carro ciscando meio de um
contrato e eu me sinto como se eu
tivesse uma cigana alumínio nos pedidos
de desculpa são as rosas em cima da mesa
o vaso você quebrou quando jogou em mim
lembra
elas são feitas de tudo aquilo que eu
não escrevi e que não falei em um
envelope embaixo das rosas são as
borboletas no estômago
algumas ainda estão vivas e eu acho que
elas também pertencem a você à final
serão sozinhas sim eu perceber que nossa
relação é muito intensa
por isso deus separou me fez sol que fez
lua e o eclipse já foi cliente se aprova
campo existe a saudade
nada mais é que o sentimento de algo que
era nosso mas que por alguma razão não
está mais com a gente
você é assinante mude eo distância
antônimo de nós eu me pergunto será que
gostar do sangue gostar de alguém é o
céu do céu eu não culpo adão por ter
comido a fruta proibida do jardim do
éden do mais afinal quem ama confio nos
separamos mas um dia voltamos
reescrevemos nossos pedidos de perdão
com manchas de maquiagem e roupas pelo
chão redesenhamos o kama sutra com gotas
de suor e desenhamos novamente a mobília
da sua casa mais contigo sempre foi mais
que isso ao seu lado e cheguei à
conclusão que sexual que a gente faz na
cama parados ou quase e amor é o que a
gente faz na rua de mãos dadas quando
transamos transamos por inteiro
fazemos nossas almas trocarem de
residência e o seu bairro pensar que a
gente antecipou no novo entre valesca e
madre teresa você é o meio termo que
todo o homem deseja encontrar as drogas
do nosso lençol tem os segredos que a
gente dividindo a cama e silence
por falar em silêncio universos colapso
na sua mudez minhas perguntas viram
monstros embaixo da cama assim eu igual
criança não quero dormir sozinho dorme
comigo
esses dias estava pensando civil onde
nasceu cego e quando ele diz sanchai e
nascer do sol ele fala de algo que ele
nunca viu
talvez o seu sorriso seja a definição de
sunshine na noite de segunda
seus defeitos e não com os meus é como
se menos com menos de si mais segundo
tributável idade é só um número bom eu
dei uma temática exceto pelo fato de que
no amor
a única contra improvável existe a soma
de 2 resulta em um e o resultado nesse
caso significa 31 filho adora o jeito
como você joga o cabelo para o lado ele
parece uma onda é como se nos dedos
afogassem os desejos cada vez que o põe
as mãos na sua nuca adora seu tamanho
nem alta com os seus sonhos em baixa com
minha auto-estima cabe no meu abraço e
abraça o mundo como se fosse seu
travesseiro
o samsung só como uma orquestra a forma
como você domina seus agudos e graves me
lembra o maestro você reza um concerto
sobre tesão e se for
ao pé do ouvido às vezes sinto tanto a
sua falta que chegou a ouvir sua voz a
sentir o perfume pelos corredores da
minha casa
já namorei com a sua sombra já conversei
com a sua fhoto meu travesseiro tem o
seu nome eu vou pra cama com você toda a
noite o seu senso de humor faria
monalisa gargalhar e só risada ea só
como uma das noites em woodstock de
jovens descobriram que o amor é inocente
e que o vilão é o coração eu queria em
garrafa sua voz para que nas noites
frias em que o mundo sente só você puder
ser qual fazendo com que a cidade
inteira sinta o que eu sinto quando você
diz alô olá e por falar em rolar você
traz um céu no seu lar e talvez nem se
dê conta do quanto eu espero seu olhar
cair sobre o mil
você me encanta às vezes pensando eu
chego à conclusão de que você é dona do
seu nariz de que o mundo se curva
perante o seu caminhar de que você além
de ser brilhante um avião mas a minha
pergunta é quando você vai ser dona do
meu sobrenome
obrigado